can you steal man
the
case that
uh the prime minister of this country
trudeau
wants the best for this country and
actually might do good things for this
country as an intellectual challenge
sure
um he seems to get along well with his
wife
he has some kids
there's no sexual scandals and he's in a
position where that could easily be the
case
he seems to have done some good things
on the oceanic management front
he's put a fair bit of canada's oceans
into marine protected areas and that
might be his most fundamental legacy if
it's real
i've been trying to get information
about the actual reality of the
protection and i haven't been able to do
that but that's a good thing so sorry
the family thing is there's somebody
speaks to his character this is a
character there is some aspect to him
who's that makes him a good man well in
that sense i mean there's the evidence
there you know i mean he's not a jeffrey
epstein profligate on the sexual front
so that's something and
his wife
they seem to have a real marriage and he
has kids so you know good for him that's
a good start by the way for a leader
yeah right right now well then i also
thought okay well
after the liberals had brought in a
harvard intellectual who was a canadian
to be their last leader he didn't work
out and then they're flailing about for
a leader and the liberals in canada are
pretty good at
maintaining
power and leadership and have been the
dominant governing party in canada for a
long time
and so they went to justin and said
well you know it's you or a conservative
and you can imagine that's not a
positive um
specter for someone who's on the left
or even a liberal especially trudeau is
quite a bit on the left and uh they said
we need you to run and then i thought
okay well
the answer to that should have been no
because the trudeau justin has no
training for this and no experience he's
not
he's a part-time drama teacher
fundamentally he hadn't run a business
he just didn't know enough to be prime
minister but then i'm trying to put
myself in this position and so it's like
okay i don't know enough but i'm young
and we don't want the conservatives and
they had had to run a 10-year run so
maybe it was time for new government i
could maybe i could grow into this man
maybe i could surround myself with good
people and i could learn humbly and i
could become
the person i'm now pretending to be
which we all have to do as we move
forward right and so and so then i
thought okay
i think you made a mistake there because
you ran only on your father's name
and you didn't have the background but
let's give the devil is due and say
that's no problem
okay so now what do you do
well you get elected and your first act
is
to make the
cabinet 50 women
despite the fact that only 25 percent of
the elected
members are female it's like okay you
just have your talent pool
that was a really bad move for your
first month couldn't ask you about that
yeah uh do you think
where does that move come from deep
somewhere in the heart or is it is it
trying to
listen to the social forces that of the
moment and try to ride those
ways towards maybe greater greater
popularity by after thinking it through
it's like no you just have your talent
pool
for cabinet positions that's what you
did there's enough cabinet positions
you know you could argue that each of
the met threshold it's like there's a
big difference between threshold and
excellent so you don't think that that
came from a place of compassion i don't
care if it could compare i don't regard
compassion as a virtue compassion is a
reflex not a virtue
you don't think judicious compassion is
a virtue wait wait a minute wait a
minute compassion can come deep
from the human heart and the human mind
i think are we talking about the same
kind of compassion yes trying to
understand the suffering treating adults
like infants is not virtuous i i see but
you're you're you well compassion isn't
treating
adults like and i mean it doesn't just
terms are you sure okay i whatever the
term is maybe
eatable compassion is
i mean i suppose i'm speaking to love
you don't think
those ideas came from
compassion
you don't think love is a blend of
compassion and encouragement and truth
love's complicated man yeah
if i love you is it compassion or
encouragement you want from me
yeah the dance love love is definitely a
dance of two to humans ultimately that
leads to the growth of both well that's
the thing the growth element is crucial
yeah
because the growth element to foster the
growth element that requires judgment
compassion and judgment well even
and have been conceptualized this way
forever two hands of god mercy and
justice
they have to operate in tandem right and
mercy is
flawed as you are
you're acceptable
it's like well do you want that do you
want your flaws to be acceptable
and the answer to that is no it's so
it's like well that's where the judgment
comes in it's like but you could be
better you could be more than you are
and that's the maternal and the paternal
in some fundamental sense
and there has to be a
active
exchange of information between those
two polls
so even if even if trudeau was motivated
by compassion it's like yeah just how
loving are you first of all
no it was a really bad decision and then
he and he's expressed contempt for
monetary policy i'm not interested in
monetary policy it's like
okay but
your prime minister
and he's expressed admiration for the
chinese communist party
because they can be very efficient in
their pursuit of environmental goals
it's like oh yeah
efficiency eh
the efficiency of the tyranny in the
service of your terror
and so and i've watched him repeatedly
and i've listened to him a lot and i
tried to do that
clinically and with some degree of
dispassion
and that's hard too because
his father pierre devastated the west
in 1982 with the national energy policy
and
trudeau is doing exactly the same thing
again and so as a westerner as well i
have an inbuilt animus and one that's
well deserved because central canada
especially the glittery literati
elite types in the ottawa montreal
toronto triangle
have
exploited the west and expressed
contempt for the west far too much for
far too long and that's accelerating at
the moment for example with trudeau's
recent attack on the canadian farmers
he's an enemy of the oil and
gas industry it's an utter and absolute
bloody catastrophe and look what's
happened in europe at least in partial
consequence and he's no friend to the
farmers
so
i've tried to steal manhattan you know i
try to put myself in the position of the
people that i'm criticizing
i think he's a narcissist
do you think there's a degree to which
power changed him
if you're not suited for the position if
you're not the man for the position you
can be absolutely 100 percent sure that
the power will corrupt you how could it
not i mean at the at the least if you
don't have the chops for the job you
have to devalue the job to the point
where you can feel comfortable
inhabiting it
so yes i think that it's corrupted i
mean look at him doubling down
we wear masks into in flights into
canada
we have to fill out an arrive can
bureaucratic form on our phones because
a passport is good isn't good enough we
can't get a passport
what if you're 85 and you don't know how
to use a smartphone oh well too bad for
you
yeah it's like
yes it's corrupted him would you
talk to him well uh if you were to sit
down and talk with him and he wanted to
talk
uh
would you
and what kind of things would you talk
about perhaps on your podcast i don't
think i've ever said no to talking to
anyone
so which is you know would you would
that be a first or would you would you
make that conversation do you believe in
the power no i'd ask you those kinds of
context no if if if if he was willing to
talk to me i'd talk because i'd like to
ask him i have lots of things i'd like
to ask him about i mean i've had
political types in canada on my podcast
and tried to ask them questions
so i'd like to know
is that you know maybe i've got a big
part of them wrong yes and i probably do
but
my observation has been that every
chance he had to retreat from his
pharonic position let's say he doubled
down
and
these
our parliament is not running for the
next year
it's still zoom in
it's still covid lockdown parliament
for the next year
it's already been
fatally compromised perhaps by the
lockdowns for the last
couple of years and this is parliament
we're talking about yeah there's a kind
of
um
paralysis fear-driven paralysis that
also
in part some of the most brilliant
people i know are lost in this
paralysis i don't think people assign a
word to it but it's almost like a fear
of this
unknown thing that lurks in the shadows
and that
unfortunately that fear is leveraged by
people
um
that you know who are in in academic
circles who aren't faculty or students
and so on are more administration and
they they start to use that fear which
makes me uh quite uncomfortable it it
does lend
people in the positions of power who are
not good at handling that power to
become
slowly
day by day a little bit more corrupt
i was really trying to figure out you
know the last two weeks thinking this
through it's like how do you know
let's say someone asked me a question
and in the youtube comments said why why
why can i trust your advice on the
environmental front
and i thought that's really good
question
okay let's see if we can figure out the
principles by which the advice would be
trustworthy okay how how do you know
it's not trustworthy
well
one
potential
response to that would be
the claims are not in accordance with
the facts but you know facts are tricky
things and it depends on where you look
for them so
that's a tough one to get right because
for example lomberg's fundamental
critics argue about his facts not just
his interpretation of them
so that can't be an unerring guide and
so i thought well the facts
exactly doesn't work
because when it's about everything
there's too many facts
so then how do you determine if
someone's a trustworthy guide in the
face of the apocalyptic unknown because
that's really the question
and the answer is
they're not terrified tyrants
i think that's the answer
now maybe that's wrong if someone has a
better answer how do you know if they're
a terrified tyrant because they are
willing to use compulsion on other
people
when they could use goodwill like
the farmers in canada objected they said
look
we have every economic reason to use as
little fertilizer as we can
because it's expensive
we have satellite maps of where we put
the fertilizer we have cut our
fertilizer use
so substantially in the last 40 years
you can't believe it and we grow way
more food we're already breaking
ourselves in half
and if you know farmers especially the
ones who still survive you think you
think those people don't know what
they're doing it's like
they're pretty damn sophisticated man
like
way more sophisticated than our prime
minister
and now you tell them no it's a 30
reduction and we don't care how much
food you're growing so it's not a
reduction
that's
dependent on amount of food produced per
unit of fertilizer used which would be
at least you could imagine it it's okay
so you're producing this much food
and you use this much fertilizer so
you're hyper efficient
maybe we take the 10 of farmers who are
the least deficient in that
metric and we say to them you have to
get as efficient as the average farmer
and then they say well look you know our
our situation's different we're in a
more northern clime the soil's weaker
you know you obviously have to bargain
with that but at least
at least you reward them for their
productivity
well it's like while holland isn't going
to have beef well where are they going
to get it well you don't need it it's
like oh i see you get to tell me what i
can eat now do you
really
okay
and
holland is gonna import food
from where that's more efficient on the
fertilizer front
there's no one more efficient than
holland and same with canada
and like isn't this going to make food
prices
more expensive
and
doesn't that mean that hungry people die
because that is what it means
so ultimately poor people pay the price
of these kinds of policies
no not known not ultimately
now today today that's a crucial
distinction because they say well
ultimately the poor will benefit
yeah except the dead ones yes
today today right
you